There have been a lot of questions about this problem from homework 2
about whether this loop would ever terminate.
In particular, the third one where knowing whether or not the loop would terminate
depended on the Collatz conjecture, which is an open mathematical problem.
This was definitely a hard question to try to make sense out of
based on what we've seen just in the class, but my hope was that that question
would get you thinking about several important things in computer science,
and I think it did from the discussion.
It may have got you thinking about them in a more frustrating way than I would've hoped,
and I'm sorry for people who found this very frustrating.
But there is some important lessons to draw from that.
The first one is that you can never make a conclusion about
how a program will behave in all cases just based on experiments.
Any interesting program has an infinite number of inputs
like that loop where there are infinitely many different numbers,
and you can't try it it for all the integers because there are infinitely many of them.
You can do experiments running it for a bunch of them and see that it always seems to stop.
The loop always finishes for all the ones you try,
but that's not enough to know that it always finishes for all input.
That's a very different claim than what you can show by any experiment.
The other point that I hope that question made, and I hope without too much frustration,
but I understand especially if you didn't find the hint that
this was a very hard thing to figure out what to do with,
was that reasoning about code and especially reasoning about properties
that depend on following paths through a code is very difficult.
It's not just difficult. It's been proven that it's impossible in general.
There is no way in general to take some code
and answer this question of whether that code always finishes.
For some code there is a way to answer that question,
and that was the case for the other two parts of that question.
For the third one, even though it looked like fairly simple code
and didn't use anything that we haven't seen in class so far
that you couldn't understand from the class.
Even for that simple code, determining whether or not that code would terminate on some input
is equivalent to solving some known open mathematical problem
that no one knows the answer to.
There are other cases where we can actually prove that it's impossible
to determine in general whether some code has some property or not.
Those are things we're not going to get into too deeply in this class.
There are things that am glad that you're starting to think about,
and we will continue t o encounter them.
I hope you'll be asking these questions and be disturbed enough by these questions
that you'll want to take a theory class later that will really get into the reason behind this
and understand the theory of what kinds of things computers can solve
and the things that they can't solve.
That was the intent of that question, and I'm sorry people found it frustrating,
but I hope you also learned a lot from that and started to think about problems the way
computer scientists think about problems by doing that.
I think we do have some people on our hangout now.
Hello. >>Hi.
So our connection with the Hangout has been a little flaky, so hopefully we won't lose it again.
Welcome. >>Hi. >>Do you have a question?
First, if you would like to introduce yourself and tell us where you're from?
My name is Michelle. I'm from upstate New York.
Hi Michelle. It must be pretty late there. >>It is. It's about my bedtime.
But I'm just actually starting today with the course,
because I flaked out a little bit.
Okay. Well, welcome. It's not too late to get started.
Than you. So I don't really have any questions.
I just kind of wanted to see what was going on and try the Hangout.
Okay. Well, we're trying the Hangout too. >>Yeah, this is an experiment.
It's an experiment, and hopefully things will work.
It seems to crash every time there's more than about 3 or 4 people that join,
so we'll see if it works better this time.
And where are you located?
We're in Palo Alto, California. >>Oh, okay. >>More people?
We have two more people here now.
Well, while we're waiting, I guess we can go to another question from the forums.
Okay. Oh, we lost Luke.
All right. So back to the forums. We talked about the Collatz conjecture.
Everyone had fun with that. Let's see.
A lot of these are suggestions.
Okay. Well, we could discuss some of the suggestions.
Homework is hard. >>More discussion about the Collatz conjecture.
I think there's almost an infinite amount of discussion on the Collatz conjecture.
Wanting live office hours. >>Well, that's what we're doing. >>We're trying.
A Google Hangout could work.
What else do we have?
The Python reference. Do you know what the status of that is?
There is a Python reference posted for each unit.
There was a bit of a delay getting it posted for Unit 2,
but there are Python references posted for both Unit 2 and Unit 3 now.
They include everything that's been covered in the class up to an including that unit.
So the Unit 3.1 includes 1, 2, and 3.
Where do we find those references?
I believe they are in the supplemental materials. Is that correct?
Yes. Below the video and the unit, you click on the supplemental materials tab.
You will see course notes for that section and also there's likes to the reference materials
relating specifically to Python.